well pretty pretty cool opponents
this is grandmaster own from the
netherlands it says but this is yes
heroin so i really got some celebrity or
physician yeah a couple of days ago i
saw him and the suggestion here of
taking on c4 and then playing e5 no idea
if this is anything decent but it's
certainly fun to try out white cannot
take because of queen d4 and the Queen
and the rook um or hanging Knight c3 of
course I have no idea how this is played
but this should apply for my opponent as
well Bishop c5 maybe if it takes then
Bishop f2 or a 495 and simply Bishop f5
maybe then Queen's Queen c2 Queen 27
really a bizarre position Oh
got to speed up mm I hope he plays it
simple but certainly strong Bishop c5
which is this is this a valid trick here
and then Queen e7
or actually 24 as strange as it looks
the taxi forum III Quincy forum
yeah I am actually saw this move as well
does he really thread anything 94 maybe
whatever take on c4 maybe plays rook c1
then it's a really weird position
oh well that take it Tarak c1e threatens
nazi form and most likely after I move
the Queen again between before
but to be honest if there's any sort of
logic in chess then wife now has some
really really strong move
night ex-nazi for for instance it's also
exposing the c5 bishop as almost hanging
not c4 Knight takes e4 Knight takes e4
Bishop Jenky form oh okay well I take on
e4
I don't think I have much choice here
but if I not take on only for what what
what is he doing them we just exchanged
it takes e5 this is so so awful for me
all right just take g7 well I cannot
retreat the bishop that's sure and
taking us also also strange move okay so
I take your phone now actually what if I
take B to take on b2 with this route
before I play let's say Queen before and
taking both the rook and the bishop then
it's got 92 at Queen c2 well whatever
you can say about this position
I've been slow okay maybe just c6 here
all the time disadvantage is really
serious now
yeah this move I'm I feared a bit time
morning let me let me take this
oh I didn't see this one is it is it
really so dramatic okay not be six
yeah of course it's still really
uncomfortable position but but maybe I
can I can somehow consolidate here well
this is this is a phone ring I just need
some some moves to do to make this
halfway playable again rook c8 is one of
them will be 97 rook c7 rook c8 and at
the end c5
yeah this seems well the society at
Perry five under 20 seconds so my check
95 is winning Kauai TM yeah this opening
experiment didn't really pay off
it was interesting but the position
looked well very difficult yeah time to
resign black resigns no I had no idea
but this opening well let's have a quick
look this of course is very committed
but yeah yeah the computer almost gives
one extra pound for white and this is
getting really traumatic now let's see
if I played here rugby rook c5 c6
yeah not much I could do it's just a bad
position when the knight on b8 and
whites pieces I'm being very active
occupying the center as well yeah this
is a opening experiment here going
terribly wrong here